The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, last time we
started in on a discussion of
a new topic, with was
statistical mechanics.
So what we're trying to do now
is revisit the thermodynamics
that we've spent most of the
term deriving and trying to
use in a microscopic approach.
So our hope is to be able to
start with a microscopic model
of matter, starting with atoms
and molecules that we
know are out there.
And formulate thermodynamics
starting from that microscopic
point of view.
In contrast to the way it was
first formulated historically,
and the way we've presented it
also, which is as an entirely
empirical subject based on
macroscopic observation and
deduction from that.
So, we looked at the
probabilities that states with
different energies would be
occupied and we inferred that
there would be a simple way to
describe the distribution of
atoms or molecules in states
of different levels.
First of all, although I didn't
state it explicitly,
essentially assumed there is
that if I've got a bunch of
molecules, and I've got states
that they could be in of equal
energy, then the probability
that they would be in one or
another of those states
is the same.
If the energies of the states
are equal, the probabilities
that those states will
be occupied.
That they'll be populated by
molecules, will be equal.
And then we deduced what's
called the Boltzmann
probability distribution.
Which says that the probability
that a molecular
state, i, will be occupied is
proportional to e to the minus
Ei over kT, where little
Ei is the energy of
that molecular state.
And then realizing that the
probability that some state
out there has to be occupied,
we saw that of course if we
sum over all these probabilities
that sum has to
equal one, right?
In other words, the sum
over all of i of P of
i is equal to one.
So that means that we could
write not just that this is
proportional to this, but we
could write that Pi is equal
to e to the minus Ei over
kT divided by the
sum of all such terms.
So now we know how to figure
out how likely it is that a
certain state is occupied.
And what it means is, let's say
we have a whole bunch of
states whose energy is pretty
low compared to kT. kT, the
Boltzmann constant times
temperature is energy units.
So if it's pretty warm, maybe
it's room temperature, maybe
it's warmer.
And there are a whole lot of
states that are accessible
because the energies
are less than kT.
What does that mean?
That means that you could put a
bunch of different i's here
whose energies are all quite
low compared to kT.
And they'll all have significant
probabilities.
Now let's decrease the energy.
Go to cold temperature.
So kT becomes really small.
So that e to the minus energy
over kT starts to, if this
gets to be bigger than kT by a
lot, then this whole thing is
a very small number.
Suddenly, you get very few
states accessible.
So if we just plot this
distribution, of course it's
easy to do, it's just a
decaying exponential.
So Pi, which is a
function of Ei.
It just looks like this.
And here are a bunch
of states.
And if we have a classical
mechanics picture of matter,
then there would just be
continuous states.
And if we have a quantum
mechanical picture of matter,
there might be individual states
with gaps in between
the energies.
Either way, what happens, what
this is saying is, if we go
out to higher and higher
energies, then you have a
smaller and smaller probability
to be in
a state like that.
And if you go to low energies,
the probability gets bigger.
And it depends on temperature.
Because it's the ratio between
the energy and kT that
dictates the size
of that term.
So let's say this is moderate
temperature.
If we go to low temperature, it
might look more like this.
Hardly any states can be
occupied because even states
of rather moderate energies,
suddenly now those energies
are much bigger than kT.
In other words, kT is measuring
thermal energy.
It's saying there's not enough
thermal energy to populate, to
knock things into states
whose energy is
much higher than that.
So you have a very precipitous
decay.
If you go to the other
extreme, of very high
temperature, then this will
tend to flatten out.
Eventually it'll decay, but
it may take a long time.
Because now kT is enormous.
So the energy has to
get to be very big.
Before it's bigger than kT.
And as long as it
isn't, then this
exponential term is not small.
So there be a whole bunch of
states that may be occupied.
In other words, a whole bunch
of states that are thermally
accessible at equilibrium.
Systems at thermal equilibrium,
molecules are
getting knocked around
with whatever
thermal energy is available.
Crashing into each other or into
the walls of a vessel.
And there'll be a distribution
of molecular energies.
And that distribution is skewed
either low or high
depending on the temperature.
So that's what that
distribution, the Boltzmann
distribution, is telling us.
This is often called a Boltzmann
factor, because it's
telling what the population of
some particular state is.
OK.
Now, this is just dealing with
individual molecule states.
Then we said, OK, what about
the whole system?
Well, the same kind of relation
holds there, too.
In other words, if these are
individual molecule energies,
now if I look at the entire
system, right well, still,
there's no reason that same
distribution doesn't hold.
And it does.
So in other words, Pi of Ei,
that's the whole system
energy, is e to the minus Ei
over kT, over the sum over i,
Ei over kT.
Now, this i doesn't refer to
a single molecule state.
We're talking about
a whole system.
It might be a mole of atoms or
molecules in the gas phase, or
what have you.
It refers to a system state
where the energy, the state of
every one of those atoms or
molecules is specified.
So this is a system
microstate.
Every molecular state
is specified.
So for a mole of stuff, that
means there might be 10 to the
24 or so molecular states that
this single subscript is
indicating.
But the point is, those
states exist.
They have a total energy.
What's the probability that the
whole system will be in
such a state?
Still going to be proportional
to the total system energy.
It turns out that these
summations end up taking on an
enormous importance in
statistical mechanics.
And the reason is, as we'll see
shortly, it turns out that
every single macroscopic
thermodynamic function can be
derived by knowing just that.
Just these sums, what are called
partition functions.
So of course they take on
enormous importance.
So, we call them partition
functions because what they're
doing is, they're indicating
how the molecules are
partitioned among the different
available levels.
The molecules or
a whole system.
So the molecular partition
function is labeled little q.
And the system partition
function is labeled big Q.
It's called the canonical
partition function.
And because they are going
to take on such special
importance, let's just look at
some of their properties for
different kinds of systems
and in general.
OK, first of all, let's talk
about units and values.
They are unitless.
This is an exponential
function.
Here are units of energy
and energy.
But this is a unitless
was number.
It's just some number, right?
Could be 1.
Could be 10.
Could be 50.
Whatever, right?
Could be 10 to the 24.
Its magnitude tells you about
more or less how many states
are thermally accessible.
Because, look at it.
And then go back to the example
that I showed you if
lots of these terms are big, are
significant because this
is really a big number, right?
It's really hot.
So lots of states have energies
lower than kT, which
means this is not too small, for
lots and lots of values of
i, then this just
keeps adding up.
And of course, same here.
So the number might
be very large.
But if we're in the low
temperature limit, maybe we're
in such low temperature that
only the lowest possible state
is occupied.
And everything else,
it's just too cold.
There's not enough thermal
energy to occupy anything but
the very lowest state
available.
Well, in that case the lowest
state, this would be one.
Essentially we could
label this zero.
We could put the energy, the
zero of energy there.
Everything else is really big
compared to kT, which means
this exponential gets to be a
really small number for every
state except one.
And this is just equal to one.
In other words, the magnitude
of these numbers tells us
about how many states are
accessible, thermally
accessible, to molecules
or to a whole system.
So let's just go through a
couple of specific examples to
try to make that a little
more concrete.
One is, let's start in
the simplest case.
Which it'll turn out
I just alluded to.
Let's consider a perfect atomic
crystal at essentially
zero degrees Kelvin.
Zero Kelvin.
So every atom.
Or even if it's a molecular
crystal, every molecule,
they're all in the
ground state.
There's no excess
thermal energy.
Every molecule is in
its proper place.
Every atom, if it's
an atomic lattice.
In other words, it's in
the ground state.
That's it.
So again, we can place the
zero where we like.
We'll place it there.
That one, for that one state,
this will be equal to one.
And for everything else
it'll be zero.
So Q is just the sum of e
to the minus Ei over kT.
It's equal to e to the minus
zero over kT plus e to the
minus E1 over kT plus e to
the minus E2 over kT.
But remember, T is
really tiny.
It's almost zero
degrees Kelvin.
So all these things are
much bigger than that.
So this is vanishingly small.
This is vanishingly small.
The whole thing is approximately
equal to one.
That's it.
Also, if we say OK, now what's
the probability of the system
being in a particular state.
Well, we have an expression
for that.
So let's look at P0.
It's e to the minus E0
over kT over the sum.
Which we've just seen.
So it's e to the minus E0 over
to kT divided by e to the
minus E0 over kT plus e to the
minus E1 over kT, and so on.
This is the only term
that's significant.
So it's approximately
equal to one.
Now, while I've got this written
here, let's just make
sure we've got something
clear.
What if we hadn't arbitrarily
set the zero of
energy equal to zero?
I mean, it's arbitrary, right?
We can put the zero of
energy anywhere.
And you might think, well, gee
that's going to have a big
effect on everything.
Well, it would have an effect
on the actual number that we
get for Q. But what you'll see
is that any measurable
quantity that we calculate
won't be affected.
It's only the zero of the energy
scale that's going to
be affected.
So for example, let's look
at this probability.
It doesn't matter where we
put the zero of energy.
This term is still going
to be enormously bigger
then the next one.
And the next one.
So in this sum only this term
is going to matter.
It's going to cancel
with this term.
So whether or not these
individual terms are equal to
one, which happens if we set
this to zero, or whether
they're equal to some
other number.
Still, the probability that the
system is in the lowest
state is one, right?
That doesn't depend on where we
arbitrarily put the zero of
the energy scale.
The state is still going to
be in the ground state, at
essentially zero
degrees Kelvin.
And it'll turn out to be that
way with any property that we
can measure.
Only the zero of this scale
moves if we arbitrarily move
it somewhere.
But the observable, measurable
quantities that we calculate,
they won't change.
Other than that scale.
So that's one simple example.
Now let's look at
another example.
Let's consider a mole of atoms,
roaming around in the
gas phase at room temperature.
OK, so now what I want to do
is just have a simple model
for their translational
motion.
And of course, we could
do that either quantum
mechanically or classically
solve for that.
We're going to use an
even simpler model.
And this model is going to be
very, very useful for a lot of
the things that we'll treat.
It's called a lattice model.
All it means is, we're
going to divide up
the available volume.
This room, for example,
into zillions
of tiny little elements.
Little volume elements.
Each one about the
size of an atom.
The idea being, we're going to
specify the state of the atom
by saying where is it.
Is it in this lattice sight,
in this one, in this
one, in this one.
So it's a lattice model.
Might be an atom there.
Might be one there.
So we're going to divide
the volume up.
So let's call our atomic volume
little v. Our total
volume big V. And an atomic
volume, it's going to be on
the order of 1 angstroms
cubed.
Or 10 to the minus
30 meters cubed.
And our room, our volume
macroscopic one, might be on
the order of one meter cubed.
Ordinary sort of size.
So now let's figure out our
molecular partition function.
Now, implicit in this, we're
basically saying that the
energy, the translational
energy, is basically zero.
In other words, all these states
have the same energy.
They're just located in
different positions.
At any given instant of time.
And what that means is all
these terms, all these
Boltzmann factors, we just
set them equal to one.
We'll set the zero of energy
there, be done with it.
It's a simple model.
But it's going to give us the
right order of magnitude that
we're after.
So, how many states are there
that are accessible?
Well, on the order of 10
to the 30th, right?
So q, little q, we'll call it
little q translational, it's
just discussing where
things are.
Is on the order of
10 to the 30th.
And if we do a more careful
treatment, if we treat the
translational energy of atoms,
either classically or quantum
mechanically and solve it.
We'll still get, we still
do get, about the
same order of magnitude.
Now let's treat the
whole system.
So, what happens?
What are our total
possible states?
Because we have to add this up
for every possible state.
Well, let's start with
the first atom.
It has to be somewhere.
It has 10 to the 30th
possibilities for
where it can be.
Let's start with the
second atom.
And put it somewhere.
Well, it has 10 to the 30th
minus one, which is still
pretty close to 10
to the 30th.
Let's let's go to
the third atom.
And the fourth.
If we have about a mole of
atoms, let's say 10 to the
24th atoms, that's still going
to occupy a very small
fraction of the site.
Only one in a million.
So we don't have to keep
careful track.
Every one of them, we can just
say, look, there are 10 to the
30th available sites.
Because we're not going to worry
about a change in one in
a millionth.
So what that means is, capital
Q, trans for the system, is 10
to the 30th times
10 to the 30th.
In other words, let's now
take the whole state.
Well, I could put
atom one here.
I have 10 to the 30th
possibilities.
Atom two, I can put
anywhere else.
So the joint probability of
that particular state, for
just the two atoms, is 10th to
the 30th times 10 to the 30th.
It's 10 to the 30th squared.
So this is going
to keep going.
It's going to be 10 to the
30th to the Nth power.
Where N is the number
of atoms, which
is 10 of the 24th.
Huge number, right?
It is a huge number.
And that, too, if we treat the
whole thing classically or
quantum mechanically and
work it all out.
We'll get that number.
Or something on that order.
Because you know there really
is a simply astronomical
number of states accessible to
the whole bunch of atoms or
molecules in this room.
It really is that big.
So in other words, capital
Q is just an
astronomical number.
And it is the case.
OK.
There's an important
sort of nuance
that we need to introduce.
And it's the following.
Turns out, it is an astronomical
number.
But a tiny bit less astronomical
than what I've
treated so far would indicate.
So let's look a little
more carefully.
What I've said is that Q
translational is little q
translational, that is, that
10 to the 30th number.
To the Nth power.
But there's one failing here.
Which is, when I got that, when
I decided that if I have
just the first two atoms I've
got 10th to the 30th times 10
to the 30th possible states, the
trouble with that is then
if I keep counting all the
possible atoms starting with
each one, I'll double-count
it, right?
In other words, what if I
interchange those two atoms?
Well, those states are
identical, right?
Indistinguishable.
And it's only distinguishable
states that count.
When you specify these
things, these are
indicating distinct states.
In some way, at least in
principle, measurably different.
If the atom's are identical, in
other words, if it's a mole
of the same stuff, I don't have
a way of distinguishing
between those two.
I have to correct for that.
And when I come to the third
atom, I have to correct for
all the possible interchanges.
Of course, it's three
factorial.
And in general, it's
N factorial.
So this result needs
to be modified.
This is true for distinguishable
particles.
In other words, if I had all
different atoms, so I could
label them all, then I don't
have that correction.
Because then there's really a
difference between that state
and the state with the two
atoms interchanged.
But if it's a mole of identical
atoms, that's no
longer the case.
So then, Q translational is
little q translational to the
N power divided by
N factorial.
It's still going to be an
absolutely enormous number.
But it's going to be a little
less absolutely enormous than
it was a minute ago.
Now finally, I just want
to introduce a handy
approximation to N factorial
that's going to turn out to be
very useful again and again.
And that's called Stirling's
approximation.
For the log of a big number,
ln N factorial is N log N
minus N. If we take e to those,
both sides, then we
find that N factorial is equal
to e to the minus N
N to the nth power.
So this, then, is approximately
equal to q
translational to
the Nth power.
Over N to the N times e to the
minus N. Now let's put the
numbers back in.
There's our 10 to the 30th to
the 10 to the 24th power.
And now we're going to diminish
that just a bit.
It's N to the Nth power.
So it's 10 to the 24th to the
10 to the 24th power.
Times e to the minus 10
to the 24th power.
So, we can cancel
something here.
So we have 10 to the 6th to the
10 to the 24th power times
e to the 10 to the 24th
power. e is about 10
to the 0.4th power.
So this whole thing is about 10
to the 6.4th power to the
10 to the 24th power
It's still a
pretty respectable number.
You could still say
astronomical.
But maybe astronomical,
but not quite to
the edge of the universe.
Whereas the one before maybe hit
the edge of the universe
and then beyond.
So that's our second example.
And again, part of what I'm
trying to do here is just
introduce some ideas.
Things like this
way of modeling
positions and so forth.
But also, again, orders
of magnitude.
How big are these numbers.
For different sorts
of systems.
So let's do one more example.
Now, let's consider a
polymer in a liquid.
And it has different
configurations.
And they might be a little
bit different in energy.
For example, some configurations
might bring
neighboring regions of the
polymer into proximity where
they could hydrogen bond.
And the point is that then the
molecular energies involved
will change a little bit.
Because of some sorts of
interactions that are possible
in some configurations.
And not in other
configurations.
So what I'm trying to do is
introduce a very simple
framework through which we
might be able to look at
things like protein folding,
or DNA hydrogen bonding.
Things like this.
And just in a simple way model
how those work and what the
forces are that drive them.
So we'll think about polymer
configurations.
So let's look at a few
Here is going to be one.
I'm going to label
this one here.
And then here are
a few others.
So I've labeled them this way
so that you can see how they
are distinct from each other.
This one would have a possible
interaction.
So we'll label its energy.
So this is molecular state
i, here's going to
be our energy, Ei.
And let's call this one
negative e int, for an
interaction energy
that's favorable.
And these will be zero.
Let's just put that there.
Zero, zero, zero.
And let's also indicate
the degeneracy.
How many states, different
states are there
with the same energy.
And that's called gi.
And here it's one.
And here are these three.
So that's the framework
of our model.
Well, so what's our molecular
partition function for this
configurational degree
of freedom?
Well, we can label it little
q configurational.
So we're going to sum over these
states. e to the minus
Ei for the different
configurations over kT.
So it's e to the
e int over kT.
Plus three times e to the zero
over kT, we'll get all those
other three terms.
So that's it.
It's e to the e int over
kT plus three.
Remember, the interaction energy
is negative e int.
It's a favorable interaction.
e int is a positive number.
So that's our result.
Now we've described the
probabilities in terms of the
states that can be occupied.
That is, we've added it up.
But of course, even the way
I wrote it just out of
convenience, I didn't
actually write out
each term in the sum.
In the notes I actually
did that.
But of course it's not necessary
to write e to the
zero over kT plus e to the zero
over kT and write that
three times for each
of these three.
Rather, it's convenient to
group them together.
And the point I'm illustrating
here is that in our
expression, for the partition
function, we've written that
in terms of the individual
states.
But we doing a sum over the
individual molecular states.
But we could also sum
over energy levels.
Including the degeneracy.
So we could say, let's not do
the sum over every state.
After all, what if there are a
hundred states that had the
same energy.
Rather than just three.
Gets to be kind of
painful, right?
Instead let's just sum
over energy levels.
They're all going to be the
same factor anyway.
And then we'll have, we'll
just explicitly write the
degeneracy in there.
So, we can write the partition
function as a
sum over energy level.
So, in other words q is the
sum over i, e to the
minus Ei over kT.
That's individual molecular
states i.
But we also could write it as
the sum over i, where this now
is molecular energy levels i.
And then we need to incorporate
the degeneracy gi
e to the minus Ei over kT.
Same thing, of course.
But again, sometimes much
more convenient to
write things this way.
And of course, we can write
the probabilities of the
occupancies in the
same way, too.
That is, we could talk about the
Pi in terms of individual
states. e to the minus Ei over
kT over q, the whole sum.
Or Pi summing over energy
levels, gi e to the minus Ei
over kT, divided by q.
Here, of course, this
is bigger if
it's degenerate, right?
It's saying that the probability
of being in this
energy level is three times the
probability of it being in
any individual one
of the states.
But sometimes it's useful
to keep track of
things in this way.
What it shows you too is that,
remember when we looked at,
did I erase it?
I guess it's gone.
When we looked at this
probability distribution for
the occupancies of the levels,
of course, what it says is at
any temperature, the lowest
level is the most probable.
For intermediate temperatures.
For low temperatures, for
high temperatures.
At high temperature, it might be
only a little more probable
than the next one over, and the
next one, and so forth.
But the very lowest state
always has the highest
probability.
But the lowest energy doesn't
always have the highest
probability because
of degeneracies.
There might be many states
with an energy up here.
And the probability of any one
of them is only a little lower
than the probability of
the lowest energy.
That could be the case here.
Let's say, the interaction
energy
isn't enormously strong.
So there is some energetic
favoring of this state.
Maybe there are 10% at
room temperature.
Maybe it turns out there are 10%
more molecules like this
than in any one of
these states.
But of course, these three
altogether mean that there are
many more molecules at
this energy than
at the lowest energy.
Now of course we could do the
same thing for the canonical
partition function.
Not just the molecular one.
So in other words, capital Q sum
over i system microstates.
e to the minus capital
Ei over kT.
But we could also write it
as a sum over energies.
Sum over system energies.
Ei.
And then we have to include
the degeneracy.
Capital Omega i e to the
minus Ei over kT.
Degeneracy of the system
energy Ei.
Little g here is the
degeneracy of
molecular energy Ei.
Now, same form.
Just an important difference,
though.
This number, this little gi, is
typically a small number.
It could be one, it
could be a few.
This number is usually
astronomical.
That's basically, that is,
what we calculated here.
In other words, how many total
system states are there with a
particular energy.
Well, in many, many, many
cases the answer is some
astronomical number.
So this number might often
be between one and ten.
This number might be
10 to the 24th.
It might be 10 to the 24th
to a large power.
And, of course, that has a big
effect on the way things end
up working.
In statistical mechanics
and in thermodynamics.
A lot of thermodynamics results
are the way they are
because you have so many
possible states with a
particular energy.
That that energy can be strongly
favored just by
virtue of the number of
states that there are.
Just the way, in a very small
way, this energy might be
favored just because there are
more states with it then there
are states here.
But again, with the
system, it's not a
factor of three to one.
It might be a factor of
10 to the 24th to
the power of something.
It might be just enormously
larger than other
possibilities that'll tend
to put the energy
at a certain place.
And just to continue, of course,
the same thing goes
for the system probabilities.
Pi, right, which is e to the
minus Ei over kT divided by
capital Q. If this is a sum over
states, or omega i e to
the minus Ei over kT over Q,
let's write this over, if now
we're calculating
the probability
of an energy level.
And it's important to make
the distinction.
Because in many cases, that's
what we care about.
What's the energy
of the system?
And we often don't care about
exactly where's that molecule
and that one, and that one,
and that one, right?
The individual states that might
be involved that would
comprise that energy.
Now, what I want to do is start
deriving thermodynamics.
Like I promised, we're going
to be able to derive every
thermodynamic quantity
if we just know
the partition function.
So now I just want
to show that that
might really be true.
So, the point is that from Q
we're going to get all of our
thermodynamics.
And let's start with
the energy.
Remember u, right?
That's our system energy.
It's an average energy.
It's an average of the energy
that we would get by looking
at the states that the system
might be occupying.
So we can write it
as a sum over i.
Of Pi times Ei.
In other words, it's going to be
determined by the energy of
any system state times the
probability that the system is
in that state.
Add them all up.
Well, we know what that is.
It's the sum i of Ei, e to the
minus Ei over kT divided by Q.
Now, I'm going to just make
a simple substitution.
I'm going to use the term beta
to mean one over kT.
I'm really just using that so I
don't need to use the chain
rule a billion times and
doing derivatives.
So I'm going to write this is
sum over i Ei e to the minus
beta Ei over Q.
So Q, then, in this term is
just a sum over i e to the
minus beta Ei.
So.
Now I do want to take
some derivatives.
If I take dQ / d beta, keeping
V and N constant, then I get
derivative with respect
to beta.
Sum over i e to the
minus beta Ei.
So that's going to bring
out Ei, right?
So it's going to bring out minus
Ei minus the sum over i,
Ei e to the minus beta Ei.
That obviously looks
like a handy thing.
Because that looks
like that term.
Then, our average energy,
remember, it's one over Q. Sum
of i, Ei e to the
minus beta Ei.
So now, it's just minus one
over q, dQ / d beta.
So that's just the same as
minus d log Q / d beta.
And now I'm going to
use the chain rule.
So it's minus d log Q /
dT times dT / d beta.
All at constant V and N. Now I
can easily get dT / d beta.
Because d beta / dT is just
minus one over kT squared.
It's just the derivative of one
over kT with respect to T.
So finally, my average E, which
is u, is just kT squared
times d log Q / dT constant
V, N. That's terrific.
In other words, if I have an
expression for Q, I know the
partition function, and I
can calculate it at any
temperature.
I just need to take log of it,
take its derivative with
respect to temperature.
Multiply it by k T squared
and I've got my energy.
Not very complicated, right?
So in other words, macroscopic
thermodynamic properties come
straight out of our microscopic
model of
statistical mechanics.
Statistical thermodynamics.
Now I'm just going to state the
next result, just because
I want to get there and it'll be
followed up more next time.
But it's the following.
You can see, of course, our Q
is a function of V and N and
T. It's a function of V because
in principle the
energies that are going
into all this can be
a function of volume.
What thermodynamic function
is naturally a
function of N, V, T?
Who remembers?
Gibbs free energy?
Helmholtz free energy?
Enthalpy?
Which one?
Nobody knows.
What's a function of N, V, and
T. Or, V and T, is what we
really formulate it as.
N was introduced later.
The Helmholtz free energy.
Thank you.
What that suggests is that
actually the simplest and most
natural connection between Q and
macroscopic thermodynamics
is to the Helmholtz
free energy.
And the result that you'll see
derived next time is A is just
minus kT log of Q. What
a simple result.
And you'll see the derivations
in your notes.
You can see it's a couple
of lines, right?
But of course, if you know A,
and you know E, you know
everything, right?
Because S is in there.
And then other combinations
can give S and G and mu.
And p.
And anything else you want.
So that's the point, is that
all of macroscopic
thermodynamics follows.
And you'll see that elaborated
more next time.
And in addition, a very simple
natural expression for the
entropy in terms of the states
available follows, that we've
alluded to before.
And now you'll see
it played out.
Right.